unfortunately my immediate professor was
incredibly resentful of anything that
was achieved by young people and so this
has had a psychological effect on me for
the rest of time painters are essential
and we have always should thank them
although we don't need to agree with
them all the time I think they are like
our guidance I would like I need to be
remembered for the extent of my
mentorship you know over 500 now
students at all levels from 50 different
countries during 50 years and I think
that will be my last thing if to society
I see myself now as an enabler for young
people to have the freedom that I think
is so important to do creative work when
they're still in their late twenties and
thirties I say to these young people you
know there are one or two older students
are there postdoctoral people who are
really really outstandingly good if
you're smart catch their tails for six
months or eight months or even a year
and just act as a technician until you
see how they operate and see experience
of life of a researcher is priceless so
whenever you have the opportunity to
listen to it go for it you have to
undergo as 10,000 hours of an
apprenticeship and after that of all
that's happening you start to think
about what is the big problem that I
might address that if I were successful
will be a contribution to science a
contribution to
[Music]